all right i'm excited to introduce our
first speaker
uh professor yuval rabbani from uh
from hebrew sorry professor yopat ravani
from hebrew university of jerusalem
professor rapani has a
long line of very influential work in
discrete and combinatorial optimization
convex optimization and so on
and without further ado i'll let him
talk about his work on
online multi-server convicts chasing and
optimization
professor
uh so let me see if i can
repeat the previous success of sharing
screen uh do you guys see the opening
slide
yes yep okay looks good
uh so yeah so i'll talk about online
multi-server
convicts chasing and optimization and
this is joint work with
sebastian bubeck and mark selkin
let me start by
refreshing your memory about k-means
clustering
or more generally the class of
center-based clustering
objective functions so we have an as
input uh a finite set
uh x um a subset of
of uh of a d dimensional real space
uh and this output we seek
uh some sort of sketch of x
um that we will denote by
uh so so the sketch will have length k
it will contain
fewer points c1 c2 through ck
these are points in rd that are supposed
to represent
x um
and the quality of this representation
will be measured by assigning uh each
point in
capital x to one of these uh
sketch points or or centers uh c1
through
ck so so we we we would
um obviously assign it to the closest uh
ci uh every point x in the set capital x
is assigned to the closest ci and then
we measure
the uh euclidean distance squared
from x to c i and we sum that up over
all
uh the points x in capital x and that's
the measure of the quality of our sketch
so this is uh at least one way uh of
of understanding k-means clustering it's
taking a
a large set of points and trying to uh
sketch it into a small set of points
uh where the sketch quality is measured
by this uh
squared euclidean distance to the
closest
sketch point measure
now there's a very natural
[Music]
online version of uh this
uh problem uh
and it goes as follows so uh
this is very natural because this is
often how
how people actually have to cope with
with with clustering problems so uh
the points in x are not known in advance
uh they are revealed gradually they they
arrive uh
in in some online fashion uh so we
we get to see x1 then we get the cx2
then we get to see
x3 and we
may also assume uh that uh
this population capital x that we're
trying to
uh to sketch uh may shift over time so
so we're getting this endless stream of
points
and um
there may be some some meaningful
clustering at some point in time but uh
uh when time progresses um
the clustering may shift because the
population changes or you know
depending on what these things actually
represent
um um
[Music]
the segmentation of the population may
change over time
uh so we can think of uh maintaining
a set a current sketch at time t
we we maintain a current sketch c 1 t c
2 t up to c k t uh
and and and this should predict uh the
point
x t
uh so um so so so we hope
that our clustering is is good and it
should be good on
future points that we haven't seen yet
but we're also allowed to move our
our centers in reaction to uh
the the input that we see over time
uh and in order to capture uh both of
these aspects of of
of of this uh setting uh first of all
that we have a good prediction
and then uh uh so so this would be the
quality of our
uh prediction and then that uh
it if if the clustering is meaningful it
can't change very quickly over time so
we want it to be relatively stable
we're we're going to uh measure um
uh both things so so the quality will be
the euclidean the the squared euclidean
distance to the closest center
of of the of the point x t
and the stability uh will be
will measure over time uh
the movements that uh the centers uh
uh do in in euclidean distance so not in
euclidean square distance
but but in a in a metric in the
euclidean metric
um okay so so so basically
uh um our objective function
uh in this online clustering problem
will be to uh do well on the sum of
these two measures
and the quality of the clustering and on
uh
plus the movement cost movement cost of
the
centers there was a question yeah can i
ask a
quick question please uh hi i'm sure
yeah the question is whether you can
choose this sketch
based on the knowledge of x t or we you
have to choose it without the knowledge
of xp
okay that's actually a very good
question so uh for now
um we will be moving the centers
uh or or at least the way i'm defining
the problem right now and
and we will actually change that soon
uh is that uh you you first move the
centers uh
you you first adjust your your
clustering and then you see what
so so you get to see xt now you can move
your centers and then you pay
uh the cost of uh of of of uh
of connecting xt to the nearest center
so
you you get to see xt before deciding on
c1t through ckt
and hence the stability measure
because otherwise uh there is no hosting
workflow
yeah okay um
now uh we can talk about um
perhaps uh a different uh problem but
we'll see that these are related uh very
closely
um or we're actually seeing it now
and that's the problem of k chasing of
convex functions
so uh we can think of um the previous
problem the online clustering problem as
follows
uh we're giving we're given a point x
sub t and
uh this point defines a convex function
the convex function f t of x is given as
follows it's just
x minus x sub t euclidean
uh distance squared between x and x t
so so this is a specific
convex function uh whose minimum
is actually x sub t and
uh we uh want to chase this convex
function now what does that
mean we have these uh uh normally when
you chase a convex function
you're moving one point here we have at
our disposal k
points and and in this case uh
there are four points so k equals four
in this example and
uh uh we're looking at a one-dimensional
space but in general it will be a didn't
dimensional space uh
and uh we're allowed to move uh
these uh the these these centers
um we have to pay for the movement cost
uh but then we also have to pay for the
service cost
and the service cost is just uh
the minimum among all these chasers
of uh the value of the uh convex
function
so so uh this part here will be the
service cost of uh chasing uh
of of um uh chasing this particular
convex function
so we get a sequence of these kinds of
convex functions and
we chase them using k chasers
and uh those of you who are familiar
with
online computing uh recognize this as
uh um just a merge of
two um well-known problems uh one is the
k
server problem in in in the k
server problem uh the function ft is
zero at
x t and infinity everywhere else so so
it's
it's a limit of uh of of some convex
function that
that that um um
uh that increases very sharply uh
when you uh move from xt uh and uh
uh the problem of chasing convicts
bodies or convicts functions it's
it's pretty much the same um
uh where uh there's only one chaser
and you get arbitrary uh convex
functions
so both of these problems are well
studied and
here here's a a very brief summary of
what's known about them
they've been they've been studied for a
very long time so
uh the case server problem was uh
introduced i think in 1988 by manassa
mcgowan slater
and um just i think a couple of years
ago
um uh there were still
uh many um advances
uh in particular the papers of bubba
ketal and
uh james lee um
that made uh very significant progress
on the randomized version
um so here as i said
f of t is zero at x t and infinity
everywhere else
um and what's known is uh that for
deterministic algorithms
uh the problem is almost completely um
uh solved so there's a lower bound of k
on the competitive ratio
and an upper bound of two k minus one
uh in the randomized case uh there's
still some
some issues uh but um uh
pretty much the lower bound is is almost
log k
and the upper bound is some poly law k
and maybe some
function of n depending on which paper
we're talking about
um so so so this is the status of the k
server problem the status of the
convex body chasing problem uh so
so convex bodies are just uh uh you you
have a convex um
uh body and uh the function is zero
inside the body and infinity outside the
body
uh but you can replace that with chasing
conflicts functions so
uh when you have one server so uh so
that's not
a very big difference uh this problem
was also introduced
many years ago by fredman and lineal i
think in 1990
1989 perhaps um
uh and here when uh so so
so i already explained the problem uh
there's a lower bound of
square root of d and an upper bound of
uh
the minimum between d and square root of
d log n so so that's pretty much uh
what's known
um about this problem uh and we're
talking now about a problem that uh
uh actually merges these two problems
and one of the issues is of course you
can work in the configuration space so
so
you you you can you can think of your k
chasers as one point in the
uh k-fold uh product of your space
but then you lose convexity so
uh so uh one way to think about this
problem is that we're trying to chase
things uh uh which are
not convex but not completely removed
from
from i mean there's some underlying
convexity
uh okay so um let's start uh with the
line
um so so we're talking about dimension
one
uh in dimension one it turns out that uh
there's a very easy solution a very well
known uh
algorithm that works well for the k
server problem on the line
a deterministic algorithm some variant
of that
works well for chasing the convex
function
k chasing of convex functions on the
line and this is double coverage
so what does double coverage do uh this
is sort of a generic situation
uh here here we have our our servers our
centers
uh c1 through uh c4
we get a new function f sub t
this is not a completely generic convex
function because it's symmetric but
uh that's what i
that was uh what i could draw uh so you
could think
of a more general thing where it's not
symmetric um
i i uh noted here
uh the minimum of of uh the
where the minimum of ft is achieved and
what we do
uh if this minimum is between two points
we uh move both of them towards
uh the minimum until the service
until the movement cost of of one of
them
is equal to uh the service cost
so so uh so uh so so they both move
uh the service cost is the minimum of of
the two service costs of each of these
points
and we move until our movement cost is
equal to the
new service cost that we reached
and this simple algorithm um
uh for the k server it's k competitive
here we
we pay an extra factor of four so one
can easily show
it's 4k competitive uh using essentially
the same potential function that is used
for the k server problem
okay so uh this is encouraging uh so
let's move on to
dimension two
in dimension two of course uh due to the
problem of uh one chasing of uh
uh of of context functions in any in
in any dimension um if k equals one
uh there is a competitive algorithm
but here unfortunately if both the
dimension and k
are equal to two were already in trouble
there is no competitive algorithm
and this follows from a very simple uh
argument
uh so uh first of all uh it's easy
to show that on the line chasing
uh the union of two segments so so so if
every request is
instead of a convict function a
convict's uh
body on the line is just a segment so
uh if we just have the union of two
convicts uh
sets two two segments uh each request is
a union of two segments and
we want to chase that uh there is no uh
algorithm that gives bounded
competitiveness
this is by reduction uh from the case
so you can mimic the k server on the
line with this for for any value of k
and because the competitive ratio
depends on k
uh as k grows uh you get unbounded
competitiveness
now here in in two dimensions uh with uh
convex sets we can emulate this
by uh replacing
each request uh in in
in the two segments in the union of two
segments on the line so so
we have a request that is the union of
two segments a
a1 a2 and b1 b2
uh we can replace this by
uh repeating
four uh requests to four uh
convex sets so the convex sets are
uh the the red segment uh the
on the top the green segment on the top
on the bottom
and these two uh um uh
yellow and uh and blue uh convex uh
uh sets that span between the two lines
if you repeat these many times then
uh the uh only
possible solution for the algorithm not
to keep paying
uh high cost is um
first of all to place one server on the
red uh
uh line and one server on the green line
and also to place both of these servers
in the same
segment on the top and the bottom so
either in the segment a1a2
or in the segment b1 b2 any other
solution would keep incurring
some cost so uh so uh the algorithm
since the algorithm knows we're going to
repeat this many times
it moves to this um configuration and
this mimics the
chasing of uh two segments on the line
so no
no bounded competitiveness uh for
chasing uh
convex functions uh in general
um but uh
k means is a specific convex function
it's it's not a generic convex function
so maybe the
um the idea of chasing a generic convex
function failed
uh maybe we can uh chase
uh k means and it turns out
that uh we can solve the online k-means
uh problem despite not being able to
chase convict sets in general
and the uh idea is as follows so we're
going to replace
our objective function
with a different objective function so
instead of f sub t which is the
convex function derived from the k-means
objective
we're going to use this ft tilde
and ft tilde is
proportional to the euclidean distance
to x-t rather than the squared euclidean
distance
uh but the factor of proportionality uh
depends on the location of our servers
so
uh ct minus one min
is the closest center to x t before we
move
so we're going to use this f t tilde
and this reduces the k means objective
function to
some k median objective function where
you're looking at
at euclidean distances instead of
squared euclidean distances
uh and and and the functions are of the
form
some um some factor alpha t
times the uh euclidean distance with
alpha t
being greater than zero
now we're also going to consider
only algorithms that we call move to
minimum
algorithms that we call move to minimum
algorithms they either move to the
uh point minimizing f sub t
or they don't move at all
okay so so these are basically the two
ideas the two ideas
behind the algorithm and uh
uh here is um
[Music]
uh an illustration uh of
of this change in potential function so
uh
in instead of ft which is the um
uh k-means uh objective
uh in red here uh we're looking at the
green objective i'm drawing this on the
line
but you should think about this as being
in high in higher
uh dimensional space um so so so we're
looking at this green objective
and for the closest uh center uh
the red and green objectives are are
equal but otherwise they
they differ so uh the green objective
underestimates the cost uh beyond the
minimum
and overestimates it uh uh
when you're closer to xt
uh and and really the problem here is uh
when the um
adversary that we're competing again
against is closer to
xt than we are because then um
then we're overestimating the the cost
of the algorithm
okay so um the actual argument goes
through a whole
sequence of reductions so we start with
online k means
um now uh we want
to um uh we
we want to uh change
uh the objective of k-means a little bit
by scaling it
so we repeat uh uh mt times
uh the function squared euclidean
distance divided by
empty so some other convex function and
mt
is chosen so that at
the uh places that we are
um the k-means objective is uh
is smaller than the uh
euclidean distance so so we choose mt to
be
big enough and we get the sequence of
requests
now we switch to um uh
move uh uh to move to minimum
uh k chasing of these convicts functions
but not just to move to minimum to blind
move to minimum
what does blind mean blind means that we
first pay the service cost
and then we move
so uh um
[Music]
is it chaba who asked the question in
the beginning
yep yes uh so so we're actually now
uh changing uh uh the game and
paying the service cost before we see uh
the the context function uh and turns
out that uh
because of the change we made in the
previous uh step
uh this doesn't matter by more than a
constant factor
now uh the next step is to s
is to switch from f t to f tilde t
uh but uh this would give us also
alpha t less than one
so so alpha t was bigger than zero it's
also less than one
and now that we have this
blind move to minimum online k median
problem with alpha t less than 1
this is easily reducible to the k server
problem
by simply um not doing anything with
probability one minus alpha t
and uh feeding the request the current
request to the k
server algorithm with probability alpha
t
so here we pay also a constant factor
and the only difficult uh case
i mean the only different difficult step
in this reduction
is moving from chasing convex functions
uh
ft to chasing convex functions f tilde t
uh and this costs us uh an extra
factor of k in the competitive ratio so
uh we will get a competitive uh algo
we will get an order k square
competitive algorithm
uh given an order k competitive
algorithm for the k
server problem um
the the argument uh um
let me go back here so uh
justin in in one sentence the argument
is that
um the the adversary can't be
too close to xt too often in the sense
that
most of its cost is uh when
its distance from xt is uh not much
closer than
than we are and that's uh thanks to the
uh competitiveness of the of the k media
of of the online k
median algorithm that uses the k server
algorithm
so this is in very briefly and uh
um without going into details uh the
crux of the argument
okay i have to just uh
okay so uh uh this sort of um
sums up the technical part i i just want
to mention that the paper
has more results so first of all the
reduction that i showed applies not only
to
the k-means objective but to a class of
uh of well-sharpened functions that
includes also
functions that are not convex uh
so so we're so we can't chase we can't
k chase all convex functions but we can
chase uh
uh a nice class of functions a
well-sharpened functions
uh the argument gives an order k
competitive online k median algorithm i
briefly mentioned that
and uh the other
points are about uh i have to explain a
little bit
so uh so far this talk was about
the uh competitive analysis genre of
online computing there is a completely
different genre of online computing
called regret minimization that is
popular in online machine in machine
learning in online learning
in regret minimization we we have to
assume some
some something about the function so for
instance
that they're one lip sheets uh on the
unit ball
uh and we also um
in regret minimization you normally
don't pay for the movement
cost uh so
uh we study uh this issue of uh
of uh uh k um
uh of of of k chasing or or in this case
k
action regret minimization as well
uh and uh there are some uh
we have some interesting findings uh
that are summed up here
um so it turns out that uh
in general uh if if you look at t
steps of uh of of chasing so so so the
idea is that you
uh you you have k chasers
uh or or k actions and you pay the
minimum of these k
actions uh so we get uh regret that
depends on the dimension
uh for arbitrary one lipschitz functions
uh we know we know how to get rid of
that
uh for linear loss functions but not in
general
and that's one of the open questions
here uh does it depend on
uh on no in the room
i'm sorry
could you repeat that
yeah uh so
that may be background nice from my side
sorry
oh okay sorry there was some noise uh
anyway
um uh so
i i guess the obvious open questions
here are is this d
here necessary uh uh
dependence on the dimension um
and um but by the way the
the algorithm here is inefficient and
that's uh inherent so
um getting sublinear regret uh
would require is is is empty hard
uh and uh i'm done basically
thank you you all uh i think we can have
like one question or two questions if
there are some quick ones
but if there are longer discussion
questions let's reserve them for the
discussion period
and meanwhile can the next speaker
stefan
set up please uh so i need to stop
sharing right
yeah yes
you have a simple question uh
there is a classic lloyd target them
right you use the clustering
which is an incremental algorithm it
updates uh the media center
and moves towards the the new point uh
is that the trivially bad argument for
the setting you considered
i'm sorry i i i didn't understand the
question
oh there is this uh my
computer is uh still playing up uh
i would just like it's a noise question
okay
never thought about these problems uh
too much
uh so the noise question is that there
is cla the classic
lloyd's argument for k-means class yeah
yeah okay
uh so what do we know about uh lloyd's
argument for these settings
um okay
that's so uh you get a new point
and what do you do you do one round of
lloyd
yeah something like that nothing
uh we don't know much or anything about
it
but lloyd could be really bad um even if
you know all the points
[Music]
okay maybe on that note like let's let's
let's discuss that in the
discussion period and let's move on to
the next